Kingdom Hearts 3 has finally been
released and whilst the finale is
dividing a lot of fans there is still a
lot to unpack from it throughout this
video I'll be breaking down the ending
of the game and giving my thoughts on
the meaning behind the final scene there
will of course be heavy spoilers here so
if you're yet to complete the game then
I highly recommend that you turn off now
but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I play it so you don't
have to in the finale of Kingdom Hearts
3 we watch as the heroes finally reunite
on destiny Island after saving the day
from Saiyan odd everyone seems like they
have all found happiness and we watch is
Carrie and Sora set on the power country
just as we think the two are about to
kiss Sora vanishes faster than Thanos
can say you should have gone for the
head and it appears that the character
is gone whilst there is currently a
wealth of speculation over whether he
died vanished or became something else I
personally believe that he was never
really there and has sadly already
passed away or went somewhere else
during this scene I think that the
heroes are actually looking over and
seeing Carrie sitting on her own crying
and they are simply imagining what it
would be like if Sora was there this is
more of a symbolic scene rather than a
literal one and I would hypothesize that
Sora sacrificed himself for Carrie the
POW putri is symbolic because in prior
games Carrie and Sora shed fruit from it
and thus their destinies were
intertwined something that Riku informed
them of at the time from this we can
imagine that the heroes are looking at
two people who shared their destinies
with one another and they are imagining
them together before coming to the
realization that Sora does not actually
exist anymore because he gave his life
he was able to get everyone else back
home except for himself and this
symbolic look at the tree showcases that
though everyone is home safe and has the
character in their hearts that he's not
actually there though their memories of
him at the symbolic location of will
forever live on while scary originally
looked sad upon touching Sora's hand in
the vision she begins to smile and I
think this is the gratitude and
happiness that she feels when she
imagines the character and all that he
did for her it's a really touching
aspect of the story that is sure to make
some gamers cry
really makes you think about the
character and the series once we don't
have any concrete answers and probably
won't for a while it's still fun to
speculate over this final scene and I'd
obviously love to hear your thoughts in
the comments on it do you agree with me
or have your own theory please make sure
you leave them below and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my breakdown of all
the endings of Resident Evil 2 remake
which we linked at the end this is a
channel for the hardcore players so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition that you've been
the best I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]